guten abend und wir beginnen die sendung
gleich mit breaking news denn die
koalitionsverhandlungen stehen offenbar
kurz vor dem abschluss noch heute nacht
könnte der ampel vertrag unterschrieben
sein vor wenigen minuten sind die
parteichefs von spd grünen und fdp noch
einmal zu bundeskanzlerin zu fahren um
sich abzustimmen ja aber vorüber darüber
sprechen wir jetzt mit unserem
chefreporter peter tiede vor der spd
parteizentrale wo die verhandlungen
nämlich heute gelaufen sind hallo peter
peta wozu denn der besuch bei der
kanzlerin heute
das ist eine quasi blitz unterbrechung
die parteichefs und olaf scholz sind hin
geheilt es geht um corona maßnahmen wie
es geht ums impfen und um eine mögliche
impfpflicht und da sie zukünftig
regieren wollen zusammen müssen sie sich
mit der kanzlerin abstimmen oder anders
um die geschäftsführung der
bundeskanzlerin stimmt sich schon mit
der künftigen bundesregierung ab und
dazu müssen sie jetzt einmal die
verhandlung unterbrechen gegen 19.30
werden die drei parteichefs oder
parteien die grünen haben ja zwei
parteiisch das werden sie hier wieder
zurück erwartet und dann wird weiter
verhandelt und so viel wie wir gehört
haben mit open end ich war vorhin oben
in der sechsten etage willy brandt
hauses wo verhandelt wird im helmut
mitunter hat man einen hohen cash mit
getränken und einen wagen mit bei
dimension ihren kaffeemaschine und der
kommentar dazu von den leuten die das
rein gefahren haben es wird wieder eine
lange nacht die letzte nacht war schon
lange da hat man sich nicht drin und den
grünen generalsekretär oder dem
bundesgeschäftsführer kellner und mit
dem haus und er sagte auch nur das wird
lange wir sind noch nicht so weit wie
wir sein
herr peter da ist spannung drin ist wird
man sogar in der leitung wir haben immer
wieder einen kleinen ton sprung wir
versuchen es trotzdem mal weiter
versuchen nochmal aufzuklären da jetzt
im bundeskanzleramt während es im bild
hier immer noch etwas blitzt im
bundeskanzleramt meine vermutung wäre
jetzt gewesen da geht es um abstimmungen
hinsichtlich vielleicht impfpflicht oder
den lockt 1 die in verschiedenen ländern
verhängt werden
es gibt natürlich ganz große probleme
beim impfen und überhaupt wie in der
korona krise wir haben ja so diese der
winter fängt so an wieder man will jetzt
genau so endet und das wieder so ein
kart wie wir es im vergangenen jahr ja
auch erlebt haben beim impfen also jetzt
bleibt es auch bei den ersten impfungen
hapert es noch bei einigen leuten und es
steht ja die impfpflicht an also die
große diskussion kommt eine komplette
impfpflicht oder bleibt es zunächst bei
der vor wenigen tagen mit dem
ministerpräsidenten beschlossenen
patienten impfen bestimmte einrichtungen
wie zum beispiel pflegeheime und
kliniken und da hat jetzt die kanzlerin
hat die drei ampel leute parteien
eingeladen in ihr bundeskanzleramt also
die alte groko und die vielleicht
künftiger ampel beraten jetzt gemeinsam
wie es in deutschland sowohl mit dem
impf und postern und natürlich auch mit
dem desaster mit der bestellung
weitergeht und was aus dem impfen
generell wird
sonst kommen dazu absolut recht das ist
das thema das hier wirklich
reinhardt in die sonst so angeblich
harmonischen ampel verhandlungen wird er
die leitung ist wirklich schlecht
trotzdem eins wollen wir noch ganz kurz
wissen wann können wir damit rechnen
dass dieser vertrag unterschrieben wird
also meine prognose im laufe des
morgigen tages das kann sein dass es
nachts um eins ist dass man da so weit
ist es kann aber auch mit dass um 11
seien also morgen muss butter bei die
fische gegeben worden sein dann muss das
ding wirklich in trockenen tüchern sein
denn der terminkalender ist relativ eng
in der nikolaus woche am besten am
nikolaustag am 6 möchte möchte der
möchte oder scholz zum kanzler gewählt
werden im deutschen bundestag bis dahin
heißt es dann natürlich wenn das klappen
soll muss der koalitionsvertrag auch
durch die parteigremien durch das heißt
bei grünen und spd das dass die
parteibasis zustimmung das ist ein
verfahren das ist nicht so einfach das
ist sich in einer halben stunde gemacht
und deswegen muss man fertig werden die
grünen haben jetzt für den donnerstag
schon ein saal hier in berlin gemietet
um den koalitionsvertrag mit der basis
durch zu diskutieren mit einem
parteirates und was sagt dieses sonal
parteitag und da muss das dann morgen
alles hier 14 meter vielen dank für den
moment an dich und sobald ist ein
neuigkeiten news gibt es natürlich für
uns vor ort und behält die
koalitionsverhandlung da im blick und
soweit es ein neues gibt's kommen wir
wieder zu dir zurück danke schön